jol oder hier soll kuranyi und heute
beginnt das war auch training zusammen
mit justin und hier kommt erstmal unser
episches intro
ja leute jetzt geht's los
wir gehen wieder auf den auf die
pyramide für mich auch gerade für justin
ohne aufgenommen die war schon sehr
ereignisreich kann man auf jeden fall
sagen und ich glaube ich hatte jetzt
bisher bei jeder der runden in
eisenstadt zum anfang läuft auf jeden
fall schon mal gut los
ein zeichen dass wir bei ware in die
mitte gehen sollten
gedacht sollten wir auch nur die rechte
von jemanden schlecken tatsächlich
suchen
als mich gut ich bin vor dir bei mir das
was du in mir leid gab ihnen kommen
erstmal bisschen was tun
na ja auf jeden fall beginnt heute das
wahre training das besagte dass wird
folgendermaßen ablaufen jeden zweiten
tag werden wir ab sofort trainings
hochladen abonniert einfach mal just wir
haben noch nicht genau geeinigt
wahrscheinlich haben aber wir werden
alle zwei tage hochladen also nicht
irgendwer auf wochentagen sind was sie
aber bist ok gestern kam nichts seines
am nächsten tag bei dem über über über
überließen sehr gut erklärt wenn ein
mann der sehr einfachen worte auf jeden
fall wird was ich halte man heute auf
jeden fall
der hatte könnte doch der hatte einst
nein also er hat auf jeden fall ein
statt ich habe meissen schwert wird das
muss er halt auch das für mich nur mainz
flaschen sehen aber ich hatte nicht das
war dem ich ganz entspannt
der einst hatte egal aber ich habe jetzt
auch cool ich habe ein schwert aber ich
hab's wirklich nicht von da ich mich auf
jeden fall leitfaden bei der weinbar
session wird sein
wir müssen jeden jeden jede session die
wir auch hier müssen wir eine runde
gewinnen
davor werden wir die aufnahme ich
aufhören weil wir wollen ja tatsächlich
gut wenn wir wollen nicht nur nicht nur
gut runden hochland sondern wir wollen
tatsächlich gut werden
und das können wir nur gewinnen so
gerade jemanden am jagen oslo sogar
getroffenen bekommst du dir kontrolliert
okay ich habe mich jetzt ein bisschen
hier bedient bei dem bei den drops die
und das kann ich mir leiste schon jetzt
kann ich mir ein feuerzeug machen da
geht es euch steht eventuell de ski hat
mit ball trainiert mit bogen
wieso hat musste dass ich muss jetzt
einfach mal sagen weil ich getroffen
habe
wieso steht bestätigt so der erste war
der mir so ein gefährt ist bei dem man
respekt haben sollte okay steaks okay
jetzt leute nimmt das nicht ernst kneuss
alter richtig schön das war teamwork ist
sehr gut sehr gut wenn dir das
ich habe auch mal eisenstadt für dich
ich finde es scheiße alter das aufkommen
im team es gehe man jedoch den gedanken
übrig bleiben kann
ich habe einfach so dass mir nicht so
wie bei der art von panik
die leute die man so einen kompass halb
von compass entfernt hat dass das wenn
man sich gegenseitig von compass
entfernt dass man dann wenn man im
deathmatch allein allein regulieren ist
dass man dann das ständig jetzt stimmt
meine bau gewinnen wir auch als team das
heißt macht dass wir gewinnen auch als
zielwasser ansage ich habe keine pfeile
wollen wir nur mit schwert und kenne
deine freunde weiß es nicht vielleicht
ist es ist gut für die übung justin
sinn der übung lassen okay okay du hast
du noch oder schlechter super ja alles
ganz einfach nur ein helm aus wie fast
dreieinhalb fehlen
ich ziehe mein ding wieder dreieinhalb
dass meine schuhe taschen genau bringt
ja nichts doch ich habe bestimmt ok bis
3.2.1 weiß relativ kurz vor der wm
zweite runde dran hängen und ich hoffe
wir kommen wieder ans set match und
diesmal kann dann justin sich
arrangieren wir sehen so leider sehen
wir auch wieder nächste runde
mal sehen ob wir jetzt wieder so gut
laufen wird oder schlechter aber
irgendwie ich habe beim luton habe ich
immer and glück habe ich das gefühl also
leute sind nie so schnell ich lasse ihn
nie lang also ich laufe jetzt nur ein
city stecker dort hier entlang
mit über die neiße sind so unnormal vier
kisten okay da wird der willig direkten
ansprachen hinter dem besser hat
erschwert
mehr nicht aber dann muss natürlich sehr
sehr cameron im tunnel da gibt's vier
klassen oder halt manchmal weniger vier
kisten der 12
hier im 3 vierter ist ja sehr stark
ich bin grad mal ins haus gegangen wäre
nämlich noch vage dass das immer hier
simons oder im haus an seinen mangel auf
jeden fall
natürlich bleibt heraus haben wir aber
mir auch gemacht weil ja natürlich
natürlich meine freunde bevor jetzt in
die kommentare schreiben
genauso unbedingt für bare trainieren
wollen diese spiele dann zwei games klar
es muss auch abwechslung sei nicht immer
so pvp an sich ist auch wichtig aber wir
werden natürlich dann auch noch bahro
spezifischere modi spielen mit dem
voranschreiten das mit debatte mit dem
abnehmen des abstandes zum war okay was
richtig wer möchte der sucht den kampf
mit mir ganz gut jetzt gelandet
ich bewege mich jetzt gerade so in
richtung mitte grob wieder mitwirken
wollten apfel um heißt und vor allem
aber nur noch als halter ich habe auch
ich bin beim bahnhof übrigens weil ich
sehr lieb hat jetzt ein so heftiges
equipment aber ich hab mir mal gelesen
da oben ist auch noch einer
du bist also bei mir in der nähe oder ja
ich bin unter ihr direkt auf fast ins
freie gelaufen
kundschaft thema ein bisschen aus ich
werde noch nicht drauf gehen wenn jetzt
hast du dein schwert für mich auch nur
noch ein holz axel ich leider gut dann
habe ich pass anfällig
er sagt es bitte jemand da oben war
einer der deshalb kann man wir
unterstehen welche nimmst du dir wohl
den und merke dass ich glaube der andere
ist hier oben drauf
also der schlechtere rüstung aber da
verteilt gut er wird okay das auch teil
war doch einer der zum versteckten abo
alter mann hat sich porsche durchaus zu
gefallen
sehr schön geht dann kommt hier runter
so das nächste mal hier bei matt auf dem
kanal läuft ich dort sehr gut als wirtin
mein bruder hier laufen gelernt haben
ich kann wieder entstanden wieder
spoiler oh mein gott schaut trotzdem
vorbei was wir entstand haben link zum
video
du kannst nicht mit deiner rene swette
sauber spaß leute homo ist okay aber wir
sind es nicht als wenn wir nicht aber
wir sind nicht games bietet die
vergleiche als wärst du nicht zufrieden
das wissen nachbarn einfach was ist wie
christus punkte hat 14 660 107 halbjahr
richtig ja sehr gut
schwerte
nein ich habe ist hier gerade 1
aufgehoben die spitze bringt rheingold
rüstung mehr als wenn dann ist schon
besser ich glaube also hose ist besser
und panzer glaube ich aber ich bin mir
nicht sicher
also ich tatsächlich besser wenn du viel
schöner anlassen vollgold mehr ist ein
unterschied oder hier wurde auch schon
genug wird leider aber ich schaue es
mich mal um als würdig ist das neue
seite auf steine raufeisen sein
ich bin hier um die feier ist super ich
könnte auch lg tnt machen aber ich
glaube ich würde mich jetzt so was
machen wir übrigens auch warum machen
wenn man zum beispiel gerade verfolgt
wird
ihr könnt auf den gegner an dann kann
man das echt mal machen wird trotz noch
gewinnen wir dürfen niemanden
unterschätzen dass die grünen gegen das
jemand lud griffen wir auf jeden fall
nicht verlassen will
maget 500 bei manchen leuten könnte man
wirklich runter springen würde trotz
noch gewinnen
jetzt wird dann wahrscheinlich aus
solidarität mit ins feuer laufen und
dann einfach verbrennen nicht dass ich
hinter ihm bin ich glaube auch nicht er
läuft sogar überhaupt keine ahnung aber
danke dass ich muss essen da er hinter
uns 28
diesen wird so uwe krupp motors geladen
ich dachte lebt noch alter der möchte er
sei tot
ich danke dir für roller ist sie ist
einfach noch gut gefüllt die küste das
ist nämlich das thema meine anfangs gut
und die leute wissen dass das mein ruth
wissen dass die nicht so schnell laufen
können wie ich und deshalb sei niemand
lange laufen
die gehen immer davon aus dass ich in
der runde dann muss man auch ich meine
jetzt ein wahrer zeit ist da ist man
auch nur in runden und spaß wir wird
üben 24/7 dass das aber nur ein kleiner
aber jedesmal anderen spielen live
stream für das spiel wurde wo ich habe
eine angel damit könnte ich dem tut ein
bisschen weh hat nicht angezündet um
schieben was kommt ich komm mir zu hilfe
george ja ich werde es schaffen nicht
essen golden ab aber ich habe aufgehört
zu wirken ja der typ der es richtig am
schalter hätten auch so gemacht er hat
feuerwehr in richtung ja ja ich habe ihr
habt euch im blick habe ich weg bin
extra umgedreht weil ich den titel
retten musste
aber leute also das mindeste was ich mir
vornehme ist dass ich dieses war nicht
aber nicht so ein pech tod sterbe ich
möchte einfach mal in einem fairen
battle möchte ich möchte ich falls ich
sterben okay da geht er hoch oder in
kurzen wasser gesprungen
er ist reingegangen richtig warum denn
auch eine team runde wenn es so krass
führt und an einem team runde geht oder
ein bisschen teenager getötet
offen lassen ein bisschen zurückfallen
oder doch nicht
es war jetzt wir haben
eingekesselt sehr schön hit gelandet
mit gelangen hertha verliert oder ich
hab dir ein gegeben das heißt müsste es
eigentlich ja ich hab alles noch ok
deswegen besser wenn man sich jetzt bin
ich auch punktemäßig von iron erschwert
machen und leute also sieht
vielversprechend aus hier muss ich
solchen bald könnte in chanten dann
könnte ich dann die erschwert entstand
das werk unendlicher ich habe auch ein
bisschen in change entmündigt werden so
packe ich noch einen ganzen korb
das ist schon sehr lakeberg was wir hier
machen kann man nicht anders sagen ja
das ist nichts das ist nichts
auf geht's fünf spieler leben noch von
daher hätte mich wunder dass gerade für
die hre diese zweite runde ist relativ
lange da aber trotzdem kassieren wir das
1 1 geschieht dass man guten gewissens
immer wieder sg bringen kann so an sich
ist es geht schon cooler spiel muss ich
meinen spielen dann waren auch noch so
ja ich hab und da geht der geht er wird
nicht so wirklich
ich weiß ist er um oder dreher
sie sind beide drinnen kommt obendrauf
nein diesen oben auf diesem dach drauf
haben gold vergessen vorsicht ja die
kommen die macht nachricht beim feuer
nein tot er hat mich einfach und sagen
okay ich probiere nicht zu rechnen
das ist natürlich erkennt aber vorne
sind die beiden ich habe leider keinen
bau im gegensatz zu denen leute die sind
alle drei da an den keller eines
inspector er versuche jetzt ein von
denen das team deathmatch keine chance
wenn müssen wir mal gucken macht ist
natürlich dann deine club alles jetzt
alter okay der kann dann ebenso schnell
laufen ja schon sehr schön
jetzt habe ich am bogen und sein team
hatten einfach im stich gelassen und
glückwunsch
ich meine schon es könnten jedoch nicht
doch nicht doch nicht der heißt no aber
er brennt jetzt zumindest arena liebig
so ließ die allerbesten weil man hier
wirklich ein bisschen möglichkeit und
taktisch zu spielen und viel platz hat
die nicht so hässlich mit bergen ist
also sondern einfach schön gerade fläche
ist kein kempen das hier ist taktisches
abwarten rademann vorne der einholt
jetzt gleich auch ein dia show ab okay
das macht es nicht leichter aber auch
noch der gute hat denn der hatte doch
ein scharfes 1 eisen schwert oder der
eine zeigt dem was ich weiß nicht hat er
nicht gerade die besten gegeben
ja derzeit dem team derzeit noch team
wie lächerlich alle was für etwas mit
was für ein witz fallen was hat
irgendwas gegen michael beck okay okay
ich probier's mal ich will zumindest
alles geben hier ja
denn die herzen ich hab noch zweieinhalb
herzlich bin die ganze zeit verdammt klo
ich war nur am anfang des kampfes folgt
aus steht also wenn wir nämlich jetzt
hier ein bisschen gut treffen mit ihren
feilen
ich bin richtig richtig richtig spannend
gerade aber ich komm zu mir so vor allem
den runden allen so dass sich so voll
schlecht bin alter ach quatsch wie bist
du bist toll rasten
ich weiß dass du so gut bist
normalerweise nicht so gleichwertig wie
wenn ja wie oft weder das noch schreiben
mit dem team alter ohne witz alter gott
ich treffe ihn einfach nicht
jahrhundert fragwürdiges spielen
natürlich trotzdem leidet weil das eine
team runde war aber leute ich glaube es
war verdammt spannend jetzt ein bisschen
länger auf jeden fall aber ich denke mal
durchgefallen ich hoffe es jacko justin
ausgang ist noch nicht gesehen habt
abonniert ihn weil in den zweiter in
zwei tagen kommt die nächste training
session trainingssession und dann sehen
wir uns wieder macht gutes und lass doch
nike kräftige info